.
WE ARE FOLLOWING THIS CASE.
LET'S JUST FIRST TALK ABOUT
WHAT'S NEW TODAY.
>> Reporter: A LOT.
FIRST OF ALL, YOU KNOW, THERE'S
A BIG ISSUE IN THE TRIAL, WHAT
CAUSED JOHNNY DEPP'S FINGERTIP
TO BE SEVERED.
COMPLETELY CUT OFF.
HE TESTIFIED WHEN THEY WERE IN
AUSTRALIA, THEY WERE AT THE HOME
THEY WERE STAYING AT.
HE WAS SITTING AT THE BAR AND
AMBER HEARD THREW TWO VODKA
BOTTLES AT HIM.
ONE BASHED AND CRACKED RIGHT ON
THE EDGE OF THE BAR AND IN SO
DOING, IT SEVERED HIS FINGERTIP.
WELL, TODAY HEARD'S TEAM PUT ON
AN ORTHOPEDIC SURGEON WHO
SPECIALIZES IN LOWER
EXTREMITIES.
HE LOOKED AT THE X-RAIES.
HE SAID I DON'T THINK SO.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> IT'S NOT CONSISTENT WITH WHAT
WE SEE IN THE DESCRIBED INJURY
PATTERN OR IN THE CLINICAL
PHOTOGRAPHS.
AND THERE ARE SEVERAL ELEMENTS.
THERE'S THE DESCRIPTION WAS A
HAND BEING FLAT ON A BAR AND THE
BOTTLE CRUSHING THE FINGER FROM
THE TOP.
BUT LOOKING AT THE IMAGES,
THERE'S REALLY NO SIGNIFICANT
INJURY TO THE DORSAL OF THE
FINGER, AND TO CREATE THE TYPE
OF INJURY WITH THAT TYPE OF A
CRUSH INJURY, WE WOULD
ANTICIPATE BOTH INJURY TO THE
FINGERNAIL AND OTHER PARTS OF
THE FINGER.
>> SO ON CROSS EXAMINATION, THE
DEFENSE WENT THROUGH PICTURES OF
THE SCENE THAT THE BUTLER HAD
TAKEN.
THIS IS IMPORTANT FORENSIC
EVIDENCE RIGHT HERE.
AND THE WITNESS SAID THAT HE HAD
NOT SEEN THOSE PICTURES.
AND IT SHOWS BROKEN GLASS,
BROKEN VODKA BOTTLES, EVEN THE
FINGERTIP OF DEPP IS UNDERNEATH
THE BAR, ACTUALLY WRAPPED AROUND
SOME PAPER TOWEL.
NOW, AMBER HEARD TESTIFIED THAT
SHE DOESN'T KNOW HOW THE TIP OF
THE FINGER WAS SEVERED OFF, BUT
SHE SAW DEPP TAKE A PHONE IN HIS
RAGE OUT OF THE WALL THAT WAS IN
THE WALL AT THE BAR AREA.
BUT THERE ARE NO PICTURES OF
THAT PHONE.
THE JURY HAS NOT SEEN PICTURES
OF A PHONE THAT WAS JUST TAKEN
OUT OF THE WALL OR THE DRY WALL
THAT HAD THE PHONE IN PLACE ON
THE WALL.
AND SO WHY DO WE CARE ABOUT
THIS?
IT'S ALL ABOUT CREDIBILITY.
BECAUSE THIS IS A DEFAMATION
CASE, AND IF YOU'RE DEFAMED,
THEN THE PERSON THAT DEFAMED YOU
IS NOT TELLING THE TRUTH